[موسيقى]
كشفه جديد في منطقه سقاره الاثريه يعود
العصر الدوله القديمه اي منذ اكثر من 4000
عام
تم العثور على مقابر ترجع لعصر الدوله
القديمه لكبار الموظفين منها مقبره ميري
مساعد القصر العظيم وكاتم اسرار الملك
ومقبره ميسي كاهن المجموعه الهرميه للملك
بي بالاول
بداخل مقبره ميري عثر على باب وهمي كان له
دور في عصر الدوله القديمه
[موسيقى]
من مصر القديمه ان هو كان بيعتقد ان الروح
بتاعته بتيجي وقت الشروق بتطلع تاخذ
جولتها وترجع للغروب هيتعرف عليه ازاي
يتعرف عليه من خلال الباب الوهمي عشان
المومياء بتاعته يا اما امام الباب الوهمي
يا اما خلف الباب لوحدي تحتوي المقابر على
مجموعه من التماثيل الملونه من الحجر
الجيري توضحوا بعض مظاهر الحياه اليوميه
للمصري القديم مثل سيده تعمل في تحضير
العجين الى جانب بعض الاواني والنصوص
الهيروغليفيه المنحوته على لوحات من الحجر
همم ناس كان مهمين جدا وواحد كان مفتش
المجموعه العالميه بتاعه الاناث اخر ملوك
الاسره الخامسه والثاني كان المجموعه
العربيه بتاعه الملك بيبي الاول فبالتالي
دول ناس في منتهى الاهميه بيعتبروا في
المنزله الثانيه بعد الملك والامراء معظم
الازهار اللي بنطلعها بتكون اسمها من زمان
لكن البير ده بقفلته من ح- من عصر الدوله
القديمه يعني حوالي 5000 سنه مهم جدا لما
تفتحي كبير وحضرتك تخش جوه وتلاقي باب ت-
تفتحيه بعد كده بتخش جوه هتلاقي ساده تطلع
التابوت تلاقي مومياء بكامل حالتها وعليها
رقائق من الذهب وعليها اسامي من الذهب ذهب
كشف مهم جدا جدا لان الذهب ما ظهرش اكثر
برده ولا مع الملوك فده بيقول لي ان في
الفتره دي كانت الافراد اغنياء وكانوا همم
بيحطوا الذهب على همم بتاعتهم لان الذهب
في مصر كان زي التراب الفضه كانت اهم طبعا
تعمل البعثه الاثريه الان في البحث عن هرم
الملكوني اخر ملوك الاسره الثالثه
سكره المنطقه الغنيه اثريا والتي ما زالت
تحتفظ تحت الرمال بالكثير من الكنوز
والاسرار خرجت منها اجمل التماثيل التي
تزين المتحف المصري سمر بشات لصباح
العربيه من القاهره